hey 42 here next time you get up in the
morning
shower and put on your freshly washed
clothes before work
spare a thought for the tashas of
victorian london
it may sound like an insult born in a
scottish pub
but a tasha was a genuine job title
given to hard-working
strong-nosed men who made their living
wading through the horrors of the sewers
that ran beneath london in the 19th
century
and i'm not talking about your bog
standard pun intended
sewer repair man that you may see
disappearing down a manhole in a hi-vis
jacket today
tasha's were in search of something more
lucrative because
beneath the layers of filth lay riches
in the form of copper silver and gold
and there was a surprisingly good living
to be had down there
for those who had the stomach in 1868
engineer joseph baseljet and his team
finished construction of the ambitious
and sophisticated
for the day london underground sewer
system
more about him later before then however
london's sewers were antiquated
overburdened
and poorly planned if they existed at
all
most areas of the city still threw their
waste into the street
where drainage channels saw its loose
underneath the feet of passing
pedestrians
londoners had been throwing their
various fluids
and expulsions into the river thames
ever since the romans packed up their
belongings and stopped maintaining their
fancy sewers
throughout most of the 19th century most
homes didn't have flushing toilets
instead the waste was sunk into a
cesspit
where it was collected every night by an
unfortunate army
of night soil men night soil men
quietly visited cesspits whilst the
respective owners
slept gathering the waste in wicker
baskets
and throwing it into the nearest river
whether that was the thames
or one of its tributaries such as the
river tyburn
wallbrook or fleet as a result london's
rivers became
large stinking open sewers
and as london grew so did the amount of
sewage in its water
to worsen matters the sewage water was
mixed with discarded awful from the
city's butchers
industrial waste from factories and
even human bodies in 1710
jonathan swift author of gull of his
travels
wrote of the river fleet sweeping from
butcher's stalls
dung guts and blood drowned puppies
stinking sprats
all drenched in mud dead cats and
turnip tops come tumbling down the flood
and as a population boom engulfed the
city in the 19th century
the problem only grew worse in 1801
london's population was about 1 million
by 1851 it had more than doubled to 2.6
million
only to double again to 5.5 million
by 1891 every day
ships arrived at london docklands laden
with exotic spices
sugar tobacco and ivory from across the
british empire
people were drawn from every corner of
the world by opportunity
and the promise of a better life but
opportunity
takes many forms whilst many secured
work in the city's factories
docks and construction sites others
out of desperation found their
opportunity
quite literally buried in other city
dwellers waste
these dejected immigrants and indeed
many british folk
began inventing new professions based on
scavenging
amongst them were fog mug collectors
known strangely as pure finders
who sought out dog poo from the streets
gathered it and sold it to lever
tanneries
bone grubbers searched through the
city's rubbish bins
to find bones to sell to soap factories
along with any other saleable scraps and
mud larks the tasha's poorer cousins
searched the thames shoreline for coins
rope and iron both mudlarks and
toshas relied on the carelessness of the
city's wealthy to make their living
though the sewers always yielded much
higher profits than the shoreline
the tashas would find and sell silver
cutlery
gold jewelry and coins that had
carelessly escaped from pockets
or accidentally thrown out with the
rubbish anything really that was lost in
london
could and usually would find its way to
the sewers
where tasha's sorted out and they earned
a surprising sum from this dirty
endeavor
the most resourceful tashas were amongst
the wealthiest of the victorian working
class
a lot of what we know of the tasha's
comes from a journalist called henry
mayhew
he published his interviews with the
city's labourers entertainers and
scavengers
in 1851. he put an average tasha's daily
earnings at around
six shillings or 35 pounds in today's
money
not mega bucks but more than double
latosha's contemporaries
atasha working six days a week could
earn himself around 36 shillings
not too shabby considering a skilled
tradesman
such as a mason or carpenter earned 25
to 30 shillings a week
and of course a tasha occasionally
unearthed
a particularly lucrative piece of
shit-soaked treasure
put all this together and according to
mayhew a tasha could average the modern
equivalent
of 20 000 pounds per annum
now tasha's may have lived well but
gosh the work was unpleasant to put it
about as modestly
as a fart and a wind turbine not to
mention
incredibly dangerous because of the
dangers posed
tasha's never worked alone but in small
gangs of three or four men
each headed by the most experienced man
they would find their way into the
sewers at low tide from the banks of the
thames
armed with fishing nets and long wooden
poles around seven or eight feet
attached to one end of these poles was a
metal hoe
that they would use to search through
the filth until they hit
something they felt was worth
investigating then their fishing nets
could be used to sift through the muck
for smaller treasure
as well as helping them locate shiny
treasure
their hoes were used to help them
clamber out
if they fell into the deep muck there
was a very real risk of drowning down
there
my what a shitty way to go a quick
thinking tasha
would find something to attach his hoe
to and pull himself out to safety
to light their way through the dark
sewer tunnels
tosha strapped lanterns to their canvas
aprons
which had numerous pockets to secure
their finds what we don't quite know
is exactly how they cleaned their aprons
hoes and themselves once they were out
of the sewers
given that this was a time when only the
richest people had bathrooms
now the thought of sinking into a
quicksand-like
soup of rotting excrement sounds
pretty darn awful but believe it or not
that was actually the least of their
worries
the most pressing of which was getting
lost
the maze of tunnels beneath the streets
of london were built over
hundreds of years with some dating back
as far as the 16th century
whilst some were just below street level
close to the greats
others were as much as 40 feet beneath
the surface
even an experienced tasha could mistake
one
dark brick tunnel for another and find
himself somewhere
he didn't expect to be then there was
the old crumbling brickwork itself
some sewers were built during the reign
of henry viii
after he passed the active sewers in
and hadn't been particularly well
maintained in the intervening centuries
so the slightest misstep could cause a
wall of aging rubble to entomb
an entire gang of toshas yet another
risk was drowning
a seasoned tosha had studied the tide
times
and committed them to memory but that
was not enough
because a surprising opening of the
sluice gates
or unexpected heavy rainfall could send
the wall of
water surging through the narrow tunnels
drowning all in its wake even the very
air itself could kill
hydrogen sulfide aptly known as sewer
gas
permeated the tunnels and is known for
its distinctive rotten egg smell
in large doses it causes the respiratory
system to shut down
and death soon follows even smaller
doses
over a prolonged period can cause
pneumonia and
yeah you guessed it death
so there we have it the tasha
protected only by a wooden pole an
unwashed canvas apron
and the lantern flame exploring the
city's dark smelly underworld
on a daily basis in search of shitty
treasure
despite this medley of morbidity
the most pressing concern for the tashas
was not presented by the syria itself
but by the city's authorities toshing
was legal and widely tolerated up until
when it was banned and so rather than
entering the sewer at dawn
as they had traditionally done so the
tashas
began working at night all of a sudden
tosha's found themselves not
only working to evade death each night
but also arrest and prosecution
they couldn't let on to anyone not least
their neighbors
about their nocturnal toshing that's not
a euphemism
because a reward of five pounds around
seven hundred pounds in today's money
was offered to informants for
information that led to the apprehension
of a tasha
take all this and throw into the mix a
tasha's subterranean nemesis
the sewer rat and you have what amounts
to an all-around
nasty career choice we aren't talking
about your average pint-sized rats here
there were legends from the day of
hordes of hundreds
maybe thousands of giant rats that had
grown
fat on food washed into the sewers
it was said by some that a mischief of
these
jumbo rats working in unison could
pin an unwitting tasha to the sewer wall
and eat him alive in minutes stripping
the flesh from his bones
one tasha interviewed by his
contemporary journalist
mayhew reported the following i've often
seen as many as a hundred rats at once
and they're whoppers in the sewers
they think nothing of tackling a man do
you recollect hearing and the man as was
found in the sewers about 12 years ago
the rats ate every bit of him and left
nothing
but his bones whilst claims of
man-eating rats
are mostly unverified large and
dangerous rats
certainly did exist with a rat bite
having the potential to cause heart
failure
meningitis or pneumonia
they were not afraid to be taken lightly
slightly more far-fetched tales
tell of feral sewer pigs that's tushas
and others witnessed beneath the city
the story went that a pregnant pig had
found her way into the sewers one day
where her litter had been born and went
on to form
an underground pig army that regularly
terrorized tasha's it's more likely that
they were just
large rats glimpsed by candlelight or
i don't know the memoir of someone who
took lsd
and watched animal farm despite their
daily profession
posing more dangers than a drunken
firing squad in a gulag
most tashas were surprisingly healthy
folk
according to mayhew they were strong
robust and
healthy men generally flouride in their
complexion
mostly between 60 and 80 years of age
who'd followed the employment during
their whole lives
perhaps though it's just a case of
survivorship bias
those who were strong enough to survive
their first few months
or years of toshing would likely endure
a lifetime of it but by the time mayhew
was writing in 1851
toshing had almost had its day london's
sewers and rivers simply couldn't cope
with the needs of its ever-growing
population
with the thames being used both as a
giant open sewer
and for drinking water the arrival of
cholera to the city
circa 1828 was inevitable
more cholera outbreaks followed along
with typhoid and dysentery
particularly in the summer months
diarrhea caused by dirty water was a
common cause of
infant death yet little was done until
in 1858 the aptly named
great stink arrived during an unusually
hot
london summer weeks of 35 degree
temperatures
caused a stench of human excrement to
rise from the river
and almost choke its inhabitants to
death those who could
left for the clean air of the
countryside those who couldn't
mostly succumbed to cholera or typhoid
as the sten swept through the city's
slums
the houses of parliament lying on the
banks of the thames
was hit hard like many other buildings
the houses had its curtains soaked in
lime
to try and hold back the stench but this
was not nearly enough
and the stink quickly overwhelmed its
inhabitants
parliament moved fast and within 18 days
had passed an act
providing the vast sums of money the
city needed
to create a modern sewerage system and
so
enter joseph baseljet who we touched on
at the start of this video
he was a contemporary a famed civil
engineer is embarked kingdom brunel
basil jets designed an extensive brick
sewer system
complete with pumping stations that
carried london's waste
out of the city it was still dumped in
the thames but much further upstream
away from most of its population where
some poor stinking farmer could deal
with it instead
if you've ever flushed a toilet in
london you'll have flushed it into a
basil jet sewer
basil jet's design included the building
of the victoria embankment on the north
side of the river
and the albert embankments to the south
these embankments hide large sewer
tunnels that
rather than spitting london's waste out
on the thames shore
carry it away upstream as well as making
it impossible for the tashas to climb
into the sewers from the river
they also changed the way the riverside
looked
and was used forever gardens
a promenade and a bandstand were all
created
turning the riverside into a place of
pleasure
and relaxation rather than scavenging
crime and more than just a
practical solution to london's sewers
the embankments were about positioning
london
as an attractive world city one in which
the filthy trade of the tashas was no
longer welcome
but if you ever find yourself in london
wandering around those embankments
perhaps stopping for a drink in the sun
or watching a show spare a fort for the
tashas
he once scrambled for a living beneath
your very feet
thank you for watching you can get your
hands on my book stick a flag in it over
on amazon or on audible links to both in
the description below
thank you